[Música]
[Aplausos]
as tendências de moda continua sendo
passageiras
elas estão baseadas na atração visual
dadas apenas pelo exterior e naquela
lógica antiquada de diferenciação entre
poesia versos plebeus que se maquiou de
evolução e vai definir grupinhos de
estilos iguais que se diferenciam quem é
legal e quem não
na verdade isso é uma extrema estagnação
frente em qualquer qualquer tipo de
inclusão para as marcas
elas querem mais é que esse ciclo se
perpetue agora os estilistas é uma
tarefa um tanto quanto inter diante
pesquisa copia modifica reproduz
para muitos essa tá essa rotina se
repete diariamente a pergunta nos dedos
os estilistas têm no mundo que não ficam
por aí pesquisando desfiles e exposições
de arte como desculpa pra definir qual
vai ser o tema da próxima coleção
eu me considero um desses poucos
sortudos que pude perceber rapidamente
que estilista na verdade é o estilo
salada mista e aí eu decidi não jogar
fora mas quatro anos de faculdade de
moda e não aceitar que minha vida seria
assim vazia e repetitiva
depois de perceber que o estilista helen
viaja muito mais para o cientista de
dados
aquele aqui para meter isa e analisa os
fatores que influenciam a venda e
desenvolvimento de novas coleções e
novas soluções e nos últimos anos vem
trabalhando com um software de
inteligência artificial utilizando a
seguinte lógica de um lado a gente tenha
a ficha técnica que ela tem o tecido a
cor o acabamento ea forma e função dessa
roupa
do outro a gente tem um marketing que
são as melhores peças vendidas as peças
mais desejadas e também aquelas peças
que foram o provador mas por algum
motivo não foram vendidas
e agora
a tarefa é recombinar ela sim e aí
quando isso acontecer o estilista vai
passar a ser a pessoa que vai decidir
dentre todas as combinações oferecidas
pelo software qual é a próxima que ele
vai lançar a mais coerente lançar
naquele momento
em uma dessas análises eu pude perceber
que o produto que levará meses para
desenvolver acabadora do ano nas araras
hoje faz exatamente quatro anos que eu
lanço um modelo novo e por que eu fiz
isso porque pude perceber que o
consumidor dela ele leva um certo tempo
para decidir
dentre todos os modelos oferecidos qual
vai ser o próximo
ele vai comprar esse processo decisório
ele não é puro impulso é uma compra
extremamente consciente pode levar meses
para se concretizar por ser pequeno
eu consegui me adaptar rápido mas eu
percebi que esses seres pensantes são
uma escala tão grande que não consigo
dar conta sozinho uma coisa que é
contraditória é o seguinte eu acredito
que aparentemente nenhuma marca é
interessante ter um cliente que pensa
antes de comprar
mas não é esse tipo de pessoa é ser
pensante
o que a gente valoriza a gente buscar
alguém para perto de nós
eu digo isso porque eu passei me
aproximar do consumidor da marca e hoje
já não é mais uma relação de venda de
amizade
só posso entender a rotina deles as
necessidades e os padrões cotidiano e
com isso eu pude enxergar que eles não
querem trocar de estilo
o que acontece é que eles estão
continuamente buscando um estilo que
expressem sua coletânea interna de dados
e também que o exterior hysén de maneira
única
mas infelizmente quando isso acontece as
marcas simplesmente trocam de tendência
em poucos meses e eles ficam órfãs
num ato de desespero eles saem correndo
comprando mais peças e também evitam
lavá las porque o tecido desgasta as
costuras enfraquecem enfim uma hora ou
outra roupa acabam falecendo
tem que enfrentar tudo isso de novo bom
eu fui buscar uma maneiras de tentar
quebrar esse ciclo de consumo que vem
seduzindo de seis para três meses e como
principal motivo o envelhecimento é
lavanderia
eu fui vou apresentar para vocês agora
os principais fatores do porque a gente
leva nossa roupa
o primeiro é o hábito na parada que a
gente já está há séculos aí
acostumados a fazer diariamente outro
ponto é a sujeira mas tem que concordar
comigo que depois de uma certa idade já
não se usa mais o do dia motor causada
por poluição e cigarro que pagar boa
notícia existe uma solução bem simples
que é pega essa roupa no varal e o vento
só vão ter que cumprir essa missão deles
em dois ou três dias
o maior e mais importante motivo do que
a gente leva essa roupa é a higiene
causada por vírus fungos e bactérias
assim tão presente no ar e também na
nossa pele e durante o nosso dia a gente
fica com receio e repetir essa roupa que
elas possam ter se instalado lá
essas bactérias elas se alimentam das
mais sutis transpirações que tem nos
pólos da nossa pele e por ela tem
contato com a roupa
elas então essa roupa se transforma em
uma plataforma dessas bactérias se
proliferem rapidamente e os excrementos
da bactéria é aquela tal do mau odor na
roupa
com essas informações em mãos assim a
minha missão foi desenvolver um produto
que não deixa a bactéria se instalar na
roupa porque o produto para limpar
contra a bactéria para matar a bactéria
o que mais tem mas não tem nada que
proteja contra elas que ele fosse também
seguro que são sucesso de um produto de
nada para se proteger
nesse momento de aplicação que ele fosse
de matéria prima orgânica e pra mim o
mais importante foi a maior missão de
todas encontrar uma solução que que não
prejudicasse as bactérias que preservam
a nossa pele chamada de microbiota a
solução que encontrei ela não estava a
introduzir mais roupas com mais
tecnologias embutidas como vinha fazendo
nos últimos anos
na verdade eu traduzi uma tecnologia que
estava no seu ambiente industrial
e trouxe ela para acesso do consumidor
final das pessoas comuns
bom só que na minha mão não aerosol e
nem piedade gás para se propagar
eu consegui traduzir essa tecnologia num
simples borrifador que quando eu aplico
na roupa limpa
dessa maneira milhões de cápsulas se
propagam no tecido
essa é uma tela de como vocês podem ver
que essas cápsulas ficam na roupa e
entrar assim tentar ser mais sintético
na explicação pra vocês um funciona da
seguinte maneira ninguém é o termo
técnico utilizado quando a gente fala do
transporte do suor de bactérias através
dos fios e fibras do tecido
quando eles entram em contato com essas
cápsulas
a função dela de proteger contra a
proliferação desenvolvimento de
bactérias é ativada ter uma noção eu
recebi feedback de vários usuários que
eles conseguiram ficar por 60 dias
consecutivos
usando a mesma roupa só que são fotos de
atletas reais que estavam usando o
produto
hoje eu estou negociando com várias
marcas de âmbito nacional e
internacional
é preciso consumir um produto mas eu
percebo que a transformação real só vai
acontecer quando houver o consumo em
massa por pessoas reais
a então o sistema em consequência do
fast fashion
o desperdício de água em coerente na
lavagem de roupa e desgaste delas
todos eles vão sofrer uma mudança e não
deixar um marco na história e todos
vocês estão fazendo parte disso
transformação está nas nossas mãos e se
dá um jeito de pensar e permitiu
perceber que é primordial antes de eu
criar uma peça de roupa nova entender o
cai mesmo tecido sobre o corpo humano e
também a necessidade das pessoas
esses dois pontos a sensibilidade de
unir eles e permitiu criar produtos num
tempo está alinhado com essa a nossa era
e na minha cabeça
hoje eu visualizo uma escala evolutiva
e nela eu acredito que o próximo degrau
a união dos players do mercado têxtil 11
gerando nivelamento social entre eles
estudantes de moda
eles têm uma noção no brasil anualmente
se formam três mil estudantes de moda
eles
tipo assim eles não estão conectados
mais com a indústria eles tenham
conhecimento que a indústria não quer e
que acontece esse conhecimento que eles
estão tentando botar em prática é tá
tendo divergente da indústria porque de
um lado os estudantes estão se
profissionalizando com novas técnicas
informações de mercado
só que do outro a indústria têxtil as
empresas continuam usando processos
oriundos ainda da segunda revolução
industrial precisa de gente que acha que
tudo isso realmente aconteça
a gente precisa colocar na nossa cabeça
a palavra-chave transparência começar a
usá lo daqui pra frente a gente precisa
mostrar pra todo mundo quem a gente
realmente é o mesmo que se isso
significa que não saber que a gente seja
demonstrado todo mundo o que nos motiva
e também a nossas experiências mesmo que
elas sejam muito poucas
mas para mim o mais importante é que a
gente deixe de se oferecer
quero dizer com isso que parece
disponibilizar para vagas de emprego
está se adaptando para elas
a gente tem que ser um catalisador da
transformação e da inovação a gente tem
que trabalhar ativamente com pesquisa e
desenvolvimento mas não aquela que a
indústria têxti conhece hoje como
pesquisa é ver o que estão fazendo e
desenvolvimento é copiar pior ou no
máximo igual pra mim
a beleza disso tudo isso está em chegar
à deficiência do outro
ali a gente pode proporcionar
oportunidades de colaboração ao invés de
concorrência e aí sim a gente pode
continuar subindo os degraus dessa vida
encontrar uma sinergia do nascer viver e
morrer que ao meu ver consiste em deixar
o mundo um pouco melhor do que quando
chegamos assim obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]